i see you have a surf club chain on for
people who don't know that is kind of
the origins
of everything you kind of came into the
game uh shout out to uh the whole surf
club [ __ ] that whole movement was insane
is this something you're gonna be
resurrecting i mean it never went away
like surf club that's just been at the
core of everything i do but you know i
started because it went it went yeah
what's that to surf club to hs87 yeah
it's just like i feel like hs 87 is like
my heart and soul of the music aspect of
what i do surf club is just the overall
lifestyle that's how i live my life just
so some awesome wavy [ __ ] like we've
been on that for years so
you know what i'm saying we i mean surf
club not to really i'm about to really
be putting out you know new music new
artists my own music just like really
pushing the lights through surf club
through the surf club so that is
officially gonna be like your label yeah
one million percent nice it's gang
though like everybody that's from surf
club they can do what they do with the
with the wave because we all started it
together
what uh
would there be any of the old hs87 guys
you try to like i always think about k
roosevelt and do me now and how perfect
of a song that was
and
it's crazy because i feel like you were
as as crazy as hs87 was somehow just the
timing wasn't right yeah i mean well
everything was changing with uh you know
dsps and you know going over from people
buying music to like completely
streaming and they were still trying to
calculate how to do all that so we got
kind of caught up in the whirlwind of of
that and i feel like not having the
right infrastructure not having the
right people on my team speaking for me
while i'm making this music because it's
hard to make the music and have to think
about the business you have to think
about all the other aspects of
everything and you had you had a pretty
serious roster too like uh it wasn't
like you just had a couple of artists
you had audio push kent money
i forget what was the young lady's name
tomorrow b-max b-mac yeah b-mac the
queen he knows k roosevelt i just like
kind of just opened up you know the
opportunities i had opened up my house
of hit era the house of hit area just
just like um
opening up the studio opening up the
opportunities for everybody to just come
do their thing and it was a
super uh like a real learning curve for
me just like on how to really move in
the game and now you kind of are
probably able to take some of those
lessons you learned and then apply them
to the surf club one million percent how
many years later is this seven years
it's about hey
what's that 2014 2017 almost nine years
bro for real well i mean we when was
granted well granted all my life was
2014 20 yeah so damn eight that was
eight years eight years i remember
hearing grinding all my life at least a
year before it came out yeah you used to
pull up yeah that's crazy and i remember
when you told me that that was your dad
rapping i was like wait a minute free
big hit too man
free or pops man i remember that was the
wildest [ __ ] because when he was like
hit boys my son no i was like wait wait
wait
yes my pops
yeah shout out to your dad man free him